elle l'eau avoue les ventes à l'eau
aujourd'hui on va parler d'eux pnl
d'enlever tout de suite les doigts de
votre clavier pour ce commentaire car
non je ne parle pas du chanteur mais
bien de programmation neuro linguistique
on va utiliser la pnl pour pratiquer une
sorte d'auto ancrage contre le stress
l'idée de cette vidéo et que vous
puissiez vous sentir plus zen sur
commande
un des outils les plus puissants de la
pnl et pour moi l'ancrage même si elle
est à la base souvent utilisés sur les
autres son utilité encore plus puissante
quand on s'en sert tu reçois aujourd'hui
nous allons créer un ancrage qui est
différent d'un pattern d'ailleurs pour
pouvoir descendre à un niveau de stress
et retrouver une émotion positive c'est
très simple vous allez commencer par ce
qu'on appelle le conditionnement positif
donc vous mettez assise ou allongée ou
vous voulez dans un endroit calme où
vous vous sentez bien utiliser des
techniques de relaxation pour vous
détendre ou de respiration comme celle
dont j'avais parlé dans la vidéo sur la
concentration détendez-vous le plus
possible vous allez bientôt déterminer
votre point d'ancrage mais vous devez
d'abord déterminer quelles émotions
positives vous souhaitez mettre dans cet
ancrage ça peut être l'énergie la joie
la motivation ce que vous les choisissez
un souvenir où vous aviez vécu cette
émotion là attention c'est pas forcément
un souvenir en actions par exemple ou un
grand souvenir de joie récent c'est
quand on m'a remis le trophée au space
c'est la sensation quand je les ai eu le
trophée en lui même au delà même du
moment physique
vous comprenez ce que je veux dire
essayer de retrouver l'émotion telle que
vous la ressentez avec donc le souvenir
adéquat décider ensuite de votre ancrage
alors il peut être physique comme ceux
touchés le ventre comme ça ça peut être
aussi mettre le doigt sur sa bague et la
faire tourner pour ceux qui ont une
bague
parce que sinon c'est moins pratique ça
peut être prendre ou voir un objet
précis ça peut même être un goût une
odeur si vous avez déjà déterminé un
jour si vous étiez plutôt visuel
kinesthésique auditifs pouvez vous en
servir pour choisir l'ancrage alors
c'est vraiment essentiel de bien faire
ce choix parce que c'est là que vous
allez place et cette émotion c'est un
horcruxe en fait ni plus ni moins
maintenant vous allez déclenché le
stimuli le point d'ancrage donc tel que
vous l'avez choisi si mon émotion
c'était la joie via la remise de
trophées et que mon point d'ancrage
était la bague je vais dans mon état de
relaxation commencé à faire ce stimuli
là en revivant le moment mentalement
donc vous restez dans cette phase de
relaxation et vous revivez pleinement se
souvenir les yeux fermés vous le
visualiser revivez le réellement prenez
tout le temps qu'il vous faut vous
n'êtes pas pressé vous pouvez leur faire
plusieurs fois en boucle comme ça mais
ressentent et sincèrement l'émotion est
associé le toujours aux stimuli et vous
venez de réaliser votre ancrage votre
taux ancrage à chaque fois vous allez
déclenché ce stimuli vous vous
retrouverez plus détendu et vous
retrouverez cette émotion par réflexe il
est possible que l'ancrage ne soit pas
assez profond la première fois ça peut
arriver même ça arrive souvent pour pas
vous le cacher alors n'hésitez pas à
refaire toutes ces étapes réguler
herman au départ peu près tous les jours
où une fois par semaine prenez soin à
chaque fois d'être en conditionnement
positif et de garder la même motion le
même souvenir et le même stimule merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo j'espère
qu'elle vous sera utile
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner puisque le
mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
durant un an du 1er janvier au 31
décembre donc rendez vous demain à 17
heures ciao
voilà
et